in an upstate New York town and all too
familiar scene and watch out buddy that
no four give her connection and our camp
like the woman in this video herb is
overdosed multiple times what happened
when herb overdosed so I walked over
here and he was just like turning purple
I kind of freaked out I I did CPR and
there was narcan but I didn't know how
to use it you know if you let me give a
second dose you give you narcan then you
just woke up really angry you first pass
through this town and and in a lot of
ways it looks like Mayberry but there's
not a public bathroom in town that
hasn't had needles in it alleyways every
alley in the city people injecting in
classrooms at Cornell University and
and boardrooms we've got people using
everywhere except where it's actually
safe to use
America is in the grip of a heroin
crisis the out-of-control heroin
epidemic facing our country is worsening
enforcement officials say heroin is now
causing more deaths than car crashes or
violent crimes we're going to the 1100
block of Hector Street for an
unresponsive person there's not any
other details on the gathered in the
summer of 2016 the small city of Ithaca
New York was losing about one person a
week to heroin local paramedic Dan
Leonard has seen addiction rates soared
what kinds of people do you see using
it's all walks of life one day it might
be a homeless person the next day it may
be an Ivy League college student in a
trend sweeping the country users here
are increasingly white and middle class
but what's different in Ithaca is the
mayor's controversial solution this is
the nightmare we must do better to do
better we must decide if mayor savant
Aymeric favors harm reduction over
punishment and he thinks this approach
could be a model for the rest of the
country at the center of his plan is a
facility where users could inject heroin
under medical supervision to prevent
overdoses there nearly a hundred centers
like this around the world the closest
is this one in an Coover Canada but none
yet in the US some say the approach
saves lives
it's been over two million injections in
this site since it opened and not one
death and others that it's dangerous and
enables harmful drug use that was
supervised heroin injection clinic I
absolutely cannot support I think it's a
preposterous idea this is the nicest
place I've ever lived
my whole life herb has been using heroin
for ten years he's been jailed over a
dozen times going public with his
addiction has come at a price
his girlfriend Janice who doesn't use
heroin recently lost her job and they're
about to lose their home now I do
something different I don't use
tourniquet
when I do it I use my my own like mine
eggs
is that it's a ritual he repeats three
or four times a day
his daily habit Coxon about $40 like
four to five heroin addicts herb started
out misusing prescription opiates he got
the pills from friends I started using
oxycontin and things like that
real heavily around 16 and around 17 18
I started IV what were you using the
oxycontin for I have traumas and stuff
from childhood I was sexually abused as
a child
herb tells me that when prescription
opiates began drying up heroin was
suddenly everywhere
as I was getting more than 1/2 pills you
know heroin started pop up more and more
and it also started to get cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper so do you wanna
clean I gotta get clean amazing things
about getting clean is my my potential
in life after his recent overdose herb
only ejects at home under Janice's
watchful eye their vocal advocates of
harm reduction keeping users safe until
they're ready to get clean mayor Meyers
drug plan includes increasing access to
treatments like methadone building a
24-hour crisis center and a detox
facility but the supervised injection
site is getting the most attention it's
currently illegal under state and
federal law but Myrick is lobbying to
change that the mayor and builders plan
months ago but it's the first time he's
unveiling it to the county legislature
he'll need their support to get MiG's
off the ground but trying to create the
first super injection facility in the
country in a small town is going to be a
tough task
I think the most compelling reason why
you would want a supervised injection
facility is that people who use it are
30% more likely to enter treatment than
people who dot who do not use supervised
injection I had a constituent asked
whether this would essentially be via
magnet and that this would be the only
one for very long would people be drawn
to Ithaca for this and where would
people think the drugs the same place
they do now so people get through drugs
on the street this is a big mental
hurdle for people they'll say well if we
open a facility then people are going to
be using drugs in our city yeah I mean I
don't want to I don't to burst anyone's
bubble but we have we have a lot of
people using drugs in our community
thank you
herb is an outspoken supporter of the
mayor's plan he says a supervised
injection facility could have saved the
lives of friends who overdosed I've lost
enough friends to incredibly preventable
yeah and incredibly preventable deaths
and um yeah ah and I'm kind of tired of
it this is something that I think should
have been considered in many places a
long time ago in his attempt to create a
safe space for heroin addicts to use
Myrick has attracted attention from
around the world we've heard from people
just down the block and heard from
people as far away as Tokyo and you know
some people think I'm brilliant and some
people think I'm I'm insane this one
just read about you plan
you are an idiot this is another way
that liberals parentheses Democrats are
ruining cities in the United States you
parentheses mayor good use of
parentheses should arrest the users not
endorse their behavior my ryx
determination to not arrest his way out
of the city's drug problem comes from
personal experience he's the son of a
crack addict having a father who was an
addict what did you learn about
addiction and the how the system treats
that the war on drugs did not save him
didn't save our family you know so for
my entire adult life I've now been in in
charge of a system that was prosecuting
the war on drugs that I knew did not
work we don't have time to waste here
losing losing too many people to keep to
keep trying the old failed methods part
of your plan calls for establishing a
place where people can legally inject
drugs the idea here is that if we're not
going to arrest people how are we going
to convince them to come in doors we
found in Vancouver Canada that
supervised injection facilities first
saved lives fewer people died second
fewer people got diseases in 2/3 more
people entered treatment the way to
truly give peace of mind and to save the
most possible lives is to legalize this
in every community in the country and
allow this to become part of a treatment
ecosystem so you buried them just last
month yes actually a month ago today I
want to go today I'm not to go today
how old is he when he started using 24
and he died at 25 yes so he was only
using for one year yes the mayor's plan
didn't come in time for the net Knox's
son Antoine Antoine overdosed and died
on Mother's Day
Lynette thinks a supervised injection
facility might have kept him alive you
know I wish they would have had that
with Antoine if they can be in a
facility that would help them you know
be safe if they overdose or whatever I'm
for it
after Antoine's death his family and
friends held a vigil in his honor
many lamented the lack of treatment
options in the community when you try to
get him treatment what was your
experience like when he did it on his
own and we tried to do it we couldn't
get him help so he willingly wanted to
get help but there just wasn't enough
help therefore yes and ethica there
wasn't enough help there he was crying
out for help and he couldn't get the
help we tried every day to get him into
treatment and we just we never succeeded
getting him in so I really believe out
here that's the only way you can get
help as if you're in trouble with the
law
the only way to get help for addiction
for addiction made a crime yeah I really
believe that across town Jennifer Hallam
is waiting for her 22 year old son a
heroin addict to be released from prison
unlike Lynette she doesn't welcome with
supervised injection site she fears her
son would go right back to using again
if there was one here it pisses me off
it really does cuz I know that would be
the first place my son be hanging out
it's just I think it'll just be out of
control the argument that proponents
make for it is that it will give addicts
a safe place since they'll be using
anyway no matter what but there wasn't
so many drugs on the streets they
wouldn't be doing it I just want to see
the government get the shit off the
street
figure out where it's coming from and
start nailing them don't promote it Bill
Russell runs a local addiction treatment
facility
he thinks the mayor is pushing an
elaborate plan at the expense of more
traditional methods that already work
there's no such thing as safe injection
of heroin safe injection should say
supervised injection site been only done
in one place in the North American
continent it's an experiment do you
think it's possible that supervised
injection could enable drug use but as
far as I'm concerned a lot of those
questions haven't been answered
I would just rather turn my time my
energy and my resources at established
interventions that will make a
difference starting tomorrow we need
detox
that's what we don't have in this
community on the surface this
neighborhood looks very different than
it become but the two communities face
the same problem the ethical plan is
partially modeled on this facility right
here in sight the first legally approved
safe injection clinic in North America
it's located right in the heart of
Vancouver's Downtown Eastside a
neighborhood with higher rates of
poverty mental illness and drug abuse
insite is the busiest safe injection
site in the world
more than six hundred injections a day
take place here no one has ever died
Bryan a former addict now works at
inside I'm a peer worker I work what my
peers who are still addicts my main job
is to make sure people are alive
upstairs above here we have a detox
center so people are actually trying to
get clean insite says its message is
simple treat people like their lives are
worth saving and they'll want to improve
LeeAnn has been coming here for years oh
this displaced um has saved my life
twice I thinking about Chad for the
first time slowly weaning myself off the
fairway as myrick pushes his plan
forward he has people likely an herb and
his father good to see you
and while Myrick faces an uphill battle
he's sticking to what he calls his end
goals a system that treats addicts as
human beings and a city where nobody
dies from drug
as America deals with its heroin
epidemic other countries face much worse
drug problems aj+ have been following
the impact of drugs around the world
from the drug war in the Philippines to
prescription drugs in India check out
the film above as well as the rest of
our series